until dawn is out this week and it'll be
the newest game to take on a theme movie
style that means it's trying to imitate
the style of low-budget commercial films
that often feature over-the-top acting
outrageous stories and exploit hooks
like extreme violence to get people
interested Tara 8 video games that have
managed to pull off the beam movie style
really well
no list about kitschy over-the-top video
games is complete without a mention of
deadly premonition so let's get it out
of the way early deadly premonition is a
polarizing cult classic game which tells
a bizarre whodunit horror story within
it's so bad it's good recreation of the
Twin Peaks television series the game
earned mixed reception and was referred
to as a ludicrous pantomime of pop
culture references and what one has to
assume is an acute awareness of its own
silliness if you like to judge your
b-movie games by their cover then here's
to game war of the monsters it does not
disappoint floor of the monsters is a 3d
fighting game whose bright colors and
towering beasties define its drive-in
movie style the game is ana mosh to
classic monster movies like King Kong
and Godzilla thanks to video games
though there's no need to be cowering
civilian because you can embody any of
10 gigantic rampaging monsters and beat
the crap out of another monster while
leveling a city if invading mankind as a
Mars Attacks style alien race sounds
like your jam then destroy all humans by
pandemic studios could be the game for
you the game gives you a lot of freedom
to create chaos as a little green men
and there are some real treats to be
found in the game's cutscenes including
a fascinating conversation between a cow
and an alien you can fly about in your
UFO and that's everything in sight while
the background music whistles
mysteriously and civilians cry out holy
smokes it's an alien seconds before
their untimely demise command and
conquer red alert 3 is the third entry
in the red alert series the less you
play through an ultimate reality of
World War 2 where Hitler never came to
power and the worst fights the Soviets
this is a real-time strategy game which
features units like war bears and
dolphins and treats players to some
truly insane plot points
good in equally ludicrous live action
cut scenes including the Soviets
traveling back in time to kill Albert
Einstein the cheesiness of dialogue is
embraced heavily and the characters are
betrayed by actors like Tim Curry Jenny
McCarthy George Takei and David
Hasselhoff if it's a balance of
exploitation style comedy horror and
gore that you're after and lollipop
chainsaw and its horde of zombies should
do the trick Juliet and her trusty
chainsaw kick around town taking out the
walking dead with the occasional help of
her boyfriend Nick now a disembodied
head hanging from / felt lollipop
chainsaw is a hack and slash game with a
bizarre sense of humor that only suda51
and grasshopper manufacture can provide
if you're on board with that brand of
weird you'll probably have a good time
the House of the Dead series has always
been pretty heavy on its silly dialogue
and zombie shenanigans but it was
overkill that decided to go all out and
embrace its b-movie nature the rail
shooter has fast paced gunplay
expletives lame one-liners and an
over-the-top gory grindhouse style full
of violence and sex games what actually
awarded the game funniest game of 2009
due in part to the interplay between the
main characters House of the Dead takes
blood and go to a brand new level and
its commitment to its style ensures that
killing off the undead isn't boring the
latest Wolfenstein games embrace that
b-movie attitude of not taking
themselves too seriously honestly they
have it all wacky alternate timelines a
meathead protagonist who spouts horrible
one-liners and plenty of nasty killing
Wolfenstein the new order is more than
happy to equip you with massive noisy
guns and plenty of baddies to point them
at the devs promise that standalone
prequel the old blood would focus even
more on the pulp themed movie vibe and
they did a pretty good job of delivering
on that with even more ludicrous
bombastic action and the addition of
nazi zombies when ubisoft announced far
cry 3 blood dragon on april first 2013
nobody will
leave that the company would create such
a ridiculous looking expansion to the
otherwise fairly serious far cry 3 but
they were serious and it was awesome
Ubisoft to described Blood Dragon as an
80s VHF vision of the future where you
need to get the girl kill off the bad
dudes and save the world it Edgard
schlocky 80s action films replace the
bright tropical world of far cry 3 with
a retro futuristic apocalyptic world
filled with neon colors and star the
sergeant Rex power cult a cyber
commander with a huge attitude problem
and the coolest name in the den galaxy
so we're down in the comments if you are
a fan of b-movie video games and which
one is your favorite I will catch you
again next week